you don't really strike me as a sort of
character who would want to throw
yourself into the limelight
how big a decision was it to have that
film made about you three what was such
a massive life event I spent a long long
time thinking about it and really asking
myself if you're gonna do this can you
commit to the idea in a way that is
gonna make a good film because I think
it did require you know lots of access
and things like you know with the birth
scene being included if things were to
end up at that point so I think that was
a good process I took myself through of
making sure I was comfortable without
before we've been talking to anyone else
about it and also all the way through
you know I instigated the project and we
all came together to work on it with the
understanding that there would be
consent at every stage not just a sort
of consent at the beginning and then
everyone's free to do what they want
sort of thing so I knew right up until
the very end of what you see in the film
that I could stop things at any moment
and that reassurance and that trust the
fact that I knew I could say that that I
you know I could withdraw magazines at
any moment meant that I had the freedom
to not do it if you see what I mean you
know how much of it of that decision
then was about doing it for you you know
and sort of documenting your own process
and dealing with your emotions in a way
that you could talk about and how much
of it was about other people in the
trans community and talking to them I
would say none of it was for me you know
I didn't do this for me at all I mean I
felt like I would be a good person to
try to make a film like this because I'm
trans but I'm also a journalist so I
knew the right people to speak tutors to
think about you know putting a team
together finding a brilliant director to
collaborate with and that sort of thing
and also just making sure that at no
point was this becoming a sort of
sensationalized simplified typical trans
story that you might have seen in the
past sort of things so I did think I had
strengths but it you know
no I absolutely did this for other
people like me who have probably been
given the same misinformation that I was
I only found out that I had the option
of starting my family in this way
through chancing across the YouTube
video of a trans man in America a few
years ago documenting his pregnancy you
know I'd been told I was going to be
made infertile by starting hormone
therapy and I'm not sure why doctors
tell us that there's no evidence for it
I think it's sort of I can understand
that it's an assumption but if you're
telling someone something that extreme
and life-changing you need to be able to
back it up that otherwise don't say it
or help people explore their options in
a truthful and open way without in a way
that's not bound by gender stereotypes
which I think often the conversations
around this are where it's just assumed
that if you're transitioning you're not
going to want to have kids because men
can't be nurturing or something to say
so yeah I wanted to under you a lot of
that how much of that then was part of
the conversation when you first went to
start testosterone therapy and you
wanted to transition was the kind of the
child bearing or you know having
children how much does that come into
the conversation with the doctors at the
time and in a mortal context it's sort
of touched upon very briefly in that
they might say to you that you need to
consider
freezing your gametes I think most trans
people are told that but not giving any
support to explore how to do that and
certainly not given any hope that it's
going to be funded by the NHS we don't
have access to that sort of support on
the NHS although hopefully that might
change in the future I know people are
working a lot behind the scenes to try
and make it so that we can access
facility services equally on the NHS but
that's it really because there's this
idea that you you either do it before
you transition or that's it so I
remember signing a consent form to start
testosterone and thinking well
this is it I just won't have biological
kids and I'll figure out what to do in
the future and I was in my early 20s and
I was desperate to transition and he
absolutely was the right thing for me to
do but I should never have been put in
that position of having to think that I
was signing away in my fertility did it
feel like a big loss at the time I think
I was just trying not think about it
because I knew I needed to start
transitioning and yeah I mean it's an
impossible dilemma and that I it felt
like an either/or choice you know I
think something a lot of people probably
don't realize is that in some countries
around the world trans people are
obliged to undergo sterilization in
order to access transition and Japan for
instance is a place that does that and
up until recently in places in Europe as
well Sweden for instance would require
you to be sterilized we this government
in the UK has always prided itself on
not requiring sterilization because
obviously it's an infringement of one's
human rights and but but by sort of
paying such little attention to trans
people's wishes to start families and
have full lives and not just the lives
that they dictate through this kind of
narrow sense of what it is to transition
it is de facto sterilization and I think
actually if we keep being given this a
misinformation even now we know that
it's not true and that there are further
options and it's very easy to support a
trans person to go through pregnancy in
the way I did and I had a very positive
experience it's criminal should be
allowed to happen either did you find
throughout the journey that there was
sort of kick back from the medical
profession or mmm no I was yeah I said I
think I was very lucky I think is that
so postcode lottery idea I encountered
wife was wonderful scenographer he's in
the film was wonderful
yeah and that's not because I was being
looked after by people who had lots of
experience with trans and gender
non-conforming people I just they're
just good people you know
you know when you get put in an
unfamiliar situation I think as a
healthcare professional how you react
comes down to just kind of the person
you are rather than your training so um
you know it's hard to be confronted with
lots of gendered forms and all that sort
of thing the whole time but actual
people were really wonderful and you
know I get that gives me a lot of hope
so how do people respond to you
initially then when you said you know
I'm thinking about having a child when
I'm thinking about having it in this way
you know in terms of out in public and
and just strangers and I I didn't ever
get sort of recognized as a trans man
who was carrying his own baby who or who
was pregnant
it's amazing actually the kind of
invisibility which on the one hand was
really hard and made experiencing
pregnancy really hard because I was
invisible and I was amazed by the forms
and all and the kind of gendering of it
all which is understandable but
unfortunate and hopefully will change
that the invisibility out in the world
was a kind of protection and I think
people just thought I was a man with a
beer belly and I was absolutely fine and
happy for them to assume that and so
yeah that that was I was more struggling
sort of internally with the feeling of
not being on testosterone but yeah I
think people read gender extremely
quickly and I had my facial hair and had
a deep voice and then people just so
they would never think oh that's a
pregnant man and it would be a wonderful
thing that maybe one day we would live
in a society where I could be recognized
for that and just go about my business
without fearing for my safety but that's
not the world we live in right now so I
was quite grateful for that for someone
like me transitioning unlocks a certain
comfort and settled earnest within
yourself it makes you feel whole it
allows you to get on with life and
just you know live the life you want to
live being off it was very very
difficult but being pregnant wasn't so
difficult so it's an interesting dynamic
being pregnant being reminded of being
pregnant with kicks and the bump relax
other stuff was quite useful quite
helpful quite grounding reminded me what
I was doing and what my job was in that
moment and reminded me why I wasn't on
testosterone which was so hard but you
know worth it so that's always something
I'm keen people to understand I suppose
that it's sort of I feel like what my
what I'm able to do with the support of
my friends and family and my doctors is
is a superpower basically and what makes
it difficult is the sort of being
invisible and worrying about being
misunderstood and worrying about the
hostility you might encounter the
experience itself needn't be difficult
if if you're just able to experience it
for what it is have you come across
people who say you just want to have his
cake and eat it and have you responded
to those people yeah I find that a
really strange idea I guess I would ask
people to examine to ask themselves
whether they whether they want kids
where they want a family like if they
don't fair enough
if they do they're maybe we're not that
different as facile is